hey you guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry
we're gonna check out the trailer for
the fifth wave that's what I was
thinking Cory grace moretz Liev
Schreiber I think this might be an
action flicker of some sort I don't know
let's watch the trailer that right the
time I've been waiting Oh Liev Schreiber
and Chloe grace Moretz hey she's 18 now
means we can make sex 19 for like years
and dudes were already hovering around
like okay yeah and now we can I know but
like I was a problem it just implies
that you've been a creeper for so well
hey man
know if you don't think it's simple to
have a knowledge that a girl under 18 is
pretty is one thing but as long as you
wait till she's 18 a jerk after it's
okay society society why I am
what
[Music]
those things drop your weapon you first
joke it's very hard to know you're human
because if you were one of them no one
shot me already
at 1:07 again the odyssey satellite
received images of an unfamiliar object
moving Brahm Livingston yeah stops 250
miles above the earth and is now
orbiting our planet we called them the
others
[Music]
[Music]
first they took our power throughout in
the world into chaos then they took our
cities laying everything to waste
[Music]
the Asian girl
next they took our lives with an
unstoppable airborne virus
worst of all they took control the
others were already among us
exterminating anyone who'd survived
the others are readying themselves for
the fit wait I have the ability to
inhabit human hosts and control their
actions they look just like us
what would you not be their fortune
would you trust a name I was supposed to
fight the others I don't know what they
are
you weren't ready for the end of the
world we've got to get my brother I'll
get you there
[Music]
what Fighter simultaneous attacks on the
last night you thought Marius the big
wave exceeds humanity will be wiped from
the face of you
[Music]
the others see our hope as a weakness
but they're wrong Oh always this is our
home
[Music]
they will not fix it it's like a weird
mishmash of like a gritty war action
movie with like a young adult novel with
like a kind of poignant sci-fi movie a
lot of people ask that I check out that
trailer really here's where you're
really upset people
looks like three different it looks like
crap I don't think it looks good at all
its components they're boys where the
moment in one movies like scenes the
moments are all right let's see if it's
based on a graphic a young adult novel
it really it reeks like one of those
trailers Rick Yancey young adult yeah
that's what I mean it looks like the
first installment in the trilogy in the
Machine it looks like all the other
young adorable because of the Machine
nothing looks original about it nothing
I like eyes with a little roland
emmerich touch to a young adult novel
that's what you get it looks it looks
like three movies to me and one of those
movies looks like it loves district 9
one of those movies looks like it's a ye
novel and one looks like it could be a
neat war movie like you know it starts
off like okay we're getting a kind of
picture that could be like sort of like
the road in a way when it first starts
off like maybe we can get it to it may
be faster Hollywood paced and then it
just goes into like this is totally a we
are because it doesn't race yeah main
characters narrative and then here's the
rules of the world here's the
terminology and here's the basic mission
of life and the basic theme our movie
will be covering yeah if you watch the
host of The Hunger Games divergent Maze
Runner and some of those some at least a
couple of those movies worked but yeah
but it just looks like there's it's all
of that well you see I feel like we've
we've crested into that point where
we're gonna play this sort of young
game of whack-a-mole or some random game
where it's like we're just gonna keep
getting tons and tons and tons of these
and then like every fifth or sixth one
will be okay maybe every tenth one will
be really good but it's just you know
this sort of dance of young adult
property because that's what's in now
this is how this feels to me I just hope
it's not [ __ ] Twilight with aliens it
looks like it might have more edge yeah
I might have a bit more of just a
bleeding-heart on it's leaving a little
less of like a soft focus romantic thing
but I don't know grace moretz delivery I
mean just a trailer but I think I feel
that way about everyone when it comes to
these young adult novels with the young
female and you know the young heroine
I'm having trouble with her and lead
roles in heroine heroine jokes are funny
heroines bad for you heroine jokes are
really funny this is the best yeah
there's a whole niche of stand-up comedy
dedicated yeah heroine shows guys come
on stage was like a big investment
serial I don't know I'm having a little
bit of trouble Chloe Moretz is like a
leading lady right now
just cuz like I don't know the stuff
I've seen her in I can I can't quite
separate her from the work so I'm always
so aware I'm watching her you know cuz
like Harry it's like she didn't sink
into Kerry for me I was always aware of
who she was she sinks into my imagine
you know I was enough thank you I mean
Chloe grace Moretz no certainly is
graceful
because we could work together not as
one not gonna do that
come on man can I help you there DCG
what you peek Reese nominates Moretz
right finish it might not even support
this hashtag No hashtag no me PC I'm
gonna have nothing I got to stop giving
you attention because that's what they
want
yeah I'm sorry to piss off all you guys
you're requested that I watch this sorry
to piss off all you newcomers who are
like it's just a trailer you shouldn't
judge the whole movie off the trailer
yeah which I'm not doing I'm giving
addictions as to why I think this will
be a piece of crap I mean you know this
is their like their pitch this is like
this is why you should come see our
movie and I don't necessarily want to
based on and it's so obvious they're not
gonna wrap up the [ __ ] story in the
first one because everything's a trilogy
yeah yeah no everything's for parts I'm
like do I really want don't want to
invest my time in a story that I already
feel like I'm not gonna give a [ __ ]
about well that's the thing is weak once
you can tell it's a young adult novel
movie
you already know sort of what you're
getting into so it's not just about
having to check out this movie it's like
there's no way to get a maze running
around or a fifth wave out and not be
like well [ __ ] I have to watch for of
yams now do I really want to start with
the first one even yeah and this one I'm
not really feeling but chloë grace
moretz might be the only reason I'll
watch it just like a look at her and
Liev Schreiber's a good actor too he is
he looks like he's taking this very he
looks like this is his new x-men origins
well perfect you commit hard to this
role because this is gonna be my big box
office breakthrough I like the idea of
like an extermination like that's an
interesting way to look at the invasion
it at least in the way they seem to be
laying it out yeah and Ron Livingston
from office space making the rounds now
he's just in the end of the tour and now
this dude Ron Livingston he's a man he's
great you used to get Paul Rudd confused
them but Paul Rudd totally different
person I warmed up to Ron Livingston
over the years so I
he's got good sarcasm anyway guys thanks
for tuning in sorry to piss off people
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you check
out reasons to Jerry and dank ass Stubbs
on this [ __ ] channel most about
everybody and you could follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope these are all possibilities
you really can do these things it's not
just like a joke and there was a shout
out I forgot to include that I did with
Noel so here's that checked
till I cry set
hey Ryan and Jerry I have answered your
channel recently from the Smosh movie
review land okay I don't know so much
about it but you are so funny with your
reactions thank you
so after the swatch video I've watched
most of your reviews I love them and if
you want to give me a shout-out that
would be great because I put a lot of
effort into the videos oh so you have
your own channel too my friend
let's see what you do let's see what
Super Trouper is about what are you 5
ding he's like little he's really tiny
but can you can you even upload 10
school life hacks Oh No can you even
like make money off you do if you're not
a team yeah it's good that you're
starting young it's good they're star
young you know build your YouTube
business now so that time you're an
adult you'll have a steady income
flowing in from the amount of
subscribers and views that your channel
generates secondly while you're online
doing that I want to give another young
person advice watch as much pornography
as you can know welcome back for this if
a man watches plenty of pornography he
becomes a much better lover so by the
time you're in college you will have
YouTube thing and you will also be a
[ __ ] sex machine that's all we
want to be sex machines famous sex
missions specifically YouTube famous I'm
like a d-list celebrity on YouTube maybe
an F list [ __ ] okay never